- But wait.
So when we talk last,
you were planning a
vacation with your in-laws.
- [Seth] Yeah.
- So how did that go?
- I spent a lot of summer with my in-laws.
I hit the jackpot with my in-laws.
- [Kelly] I've heard you say this.
- They're wonderful.
They're incredible grandparents.
And they do a thing,
it's really special to me,
which is they love their
daughter as much as I do.
But there are a few times when
my wife and I are fighting,
my in-laws will take my side,
(audience gasps)
not verbally
but you know when you're
having a fight with a spouse
sometimes this means the world.
They'll just do their thing
and then look at me and go.
(audience laughs)
And it's like that just
helps you get through it.
They're basically saying,
look-
- You're not alone.
- I can't jump in and
take the brunt of this.
I am ultimately a coward.
(audience laughs)
but I want you to know that,
hearing both sides of this fight,
I realize that you're right.
And I want to roll my
eyes at you to give you
just that connection-
- That's nice.
Just the connection of not
feeling alone on an island.
- It's very special.
- Yes
But then you're also frustrated
cause you're like, say something.
- Well, I am not that frustrated
because my wife will often,
not often, but sometimes
fight with her parents
and then I will do the same thing.
I won't actually jump in and help.
But I will then look at them
and give them the return, like...
- Maybe this is my issue.
I'm way too honest.
Maybe that's my...(laughs)
- Oh yeah.
Honesty's a real dead end.
- That gets you nowhere.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
I can't believe you've
been an honest person
in show business and done so well
for yourself.
- I know. (laughing)
It's a fluke.
- It really speaks
to your talents.
- It's a fluke. (laughing)
- It really speaks
to your talents.
Yeah.
- Yeah. I dunno. (laughing)
(audience laughs and cheers)
But you told us how last
time you lied to your dad.
So I'm wondering if you're...
Oh, fine.
I know, is Gloria like
"Holy, this is my work."
And I'm gonna like...
Should I just the whole time?
Am I gonna be Beyonce-
- We're gonna...
- this entire interview?
(audience cheers)
I was like, I know, I look
like Blake Shelton on stage
at a concert.
(audience laughs)
I'm sweating
so much right now.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
- [Seth] Yeah.
- I'll do it low.
But no, but you told us... I
have a fan now, (Seth laughs)
for camera's sake, I'm gonna say this.
I have a fan now because
I'm sweating my behind off.
- Yeah.
- So, yep.
I'm gonna look like Beyonce
this entire interview.
Here we go. I'm gonna do it
like this too. (Seth laughs)
So...
(Audience cheers)
You told us
that you lied to your dad the last time
that we talked.
So wait, has your son,
does he lie to you now?
- The five-year-old is a liar,
(audience laughs)
but he developed, it's
just like a human thing
to develop.
Like, he's done this
thing now where he'll say
he's having a nightmare.
And then when you start
asking questions about
what the nightmare was-
- Yes.
- he kind of moves on to like,
"I will tell you about that,
but there is this toy
helicopter," and you're like
is this, was this whole
thing cause you wanted
to talk about a toy helicopter
at four in the morning?
So that's where we're starting
to sense this.
- I'm wondering
if it's like a little boy thing,
cause my little girl is terrified,
kind of, to lie.
She'll tell on herself, she's terrified.
My son will in your face,
you've just watched him do it,
say, "I did not do it."
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- And I am like, you know what,
points for bold, being bold.
- The three year old
has, is without guile,
so he's incapable of lying.
So it's really fun when we'll say,
"Do not get up from the table,
I'm telling you not to
get up at the table."
And he'll just say like,
"I'm gonna break the rules."
(audience laughs)
- That's funny.
- So he's like,
"I know, I hear you, but I'm
not gonna listen to you."
(audience laughs)
- (laughing) "I do not respect you."
- (laughing) Yeah.